if you want to have an honest
conversation about race on the internet
here's what you do
you set your computer on fire you flee
to the forest you drink a mimosa laced
with toad venom and you simply wait for
the Wolverines to eat your legs trust me
you're better off that way because if
you look for videos on YouTube about
race well here's what you got you get
fascism racist pseudoscience racists
debate fascists tag team title match
tonight at nine or if you're lucky you
got this so perhaps our legal system
isn't going around willy-nilly
convicting innocent black people of
crimes they didn't commit
perhaps individuals who happen to be
black are making bad choices for which
they have to deal with the consequences
racism isn't the explanation for
everything bad that happens to black
people if blacks are getting a shot and
going to jail more it's their fault for
committing crimes that's right
racial inequality in America exists
because black people simply decide to
commit more crimes for no reason I guess
he's probably gonna blame the rap music
or deadbeat dads with their sagging
pants I'd say that this is the most
common right-wing view of rates in
America it's not outright fascism or
race realism but simply the classical
liberal view that racial inequality is
the product not of injustice but of
black people simply deciding to make bad
choices
usually this idea gets whipped out as a
way to wave away the indisputable facts
of racial inequality and dismiss those
pesky protesters always complaining
about things mmm they make me
uncomfortable and I don't like it this
is what I'm gonna argue against in this
video we're gonna take a break from
talking about fascism in the past I
focused too much on the alright I think
we all have I mean don't get me wrong it
definitely is a dangerous movement but
it's just not the most consequential
kind of white supremacy that exists in
America in this video I want to talk
about the real root of racial inequality
in America which is the structural
injustice that disadvantage as many
people of color and from now on I'm
gonna try not to get so distracted by
this circus sideshow of peppe's and
racist Oh Dennis and neo-nazi LARPers
all that stuff it's very last season I'm
kind of over it oh god damn it hello
later Fritz get the hell out of here no
one cares about you anymore now a nice
house Anita half its name against Playa
what if Ben gets an F oh great get out
well don't you want to hear about my
transition
oh I don't care no one cares you're
still a Nazi get out but I'm trans how
could I possibly be a Nazi that's a good
question it's almost as if you're an
irrational person in your worldview
makes no sense get out she calls me a
Nazi and yet she is the one trying to
silence my free speech an excellent
example of how truly fascist the left
has become look if your ideas stand up
to rational scrutiny why aren't you
willing to discuss them in the free
marketplace of ideas I'm going to
discuss them in the free marketplace of
ideas as soon as you get out of my room
mom get out of my life well can we at
least talk about the Jewish Question no
it's just ideas what are you afraid of
I'm afraid that I'm going to have to
blow the tabie whistle if you don't get
out of here in ten seconds ten nine Oh
baby come on I thought you would like to
think we used to whisper to me so
sweetly well not anymore
but do you at least want to buy some
bite aloe max hey Jesus I don't like
doing this I prefer to have
conversations about disagreements I
don't enjoy waving a bat around and
hissing like a cat but it's these people
they just give you no choice where were
we
right so racial injustice when I talk to
people about this issue they often claim
to have this experience that leftists
react to them in two ways one by saying
you're racist and two by saying it's not
my job to educate you and I'm sure this
isn't as universal as people say it is
but it does seem to be an experience a
lot of people have and that's not good
because most people are pretty ignorant
about this no offense and there's no
shortage of fascists race realists and
classical liberals who are more than
happy to educate people in their own
special way
so as I see it the left needs to step it
up now to be fair if you're bothering
random people of color on Twitter to
demand they explain racism to you you're
being kind of an [ __ ] and it's true
it's not their job to explain it to you
they have other [ __ ] to do with their
lives but I on the other hand do not
have anything better to do than swerve
wildly out of my lane and whites blame
racism to you for the next 20 minutes
because it kind of is my job and I have
all the time in the world it's a funny
thing time whose job is it to mend the
crimes of history do we have to take
responsibility for things that happened
along
I'm ago I don't even take responsibility
for things I did before July this person
who the [ __ ] is that
no I don't have any white guilt that's
not what this is about
that's just more weight narcissism is
what that is so wipe away those white
ass tears here I'll pick you out a
cotton ball
[Music]
one Freddie gray on April 12 2015
three police officers near a housing
project in West Baltimore arrested a 25
year old black man named Freddie gray
because he was carrying a
spring-assisted knife that maybe was
illegal they handcuffed him and loaded
him into a police van and the van
arrived at the police station Gray was
in a coma for some reason with three
fractured vertebrae and his spine 80%
severed at the neck a week later gray
died of his spinal injury while the
Baltimore Police released contradictory
and inadequate information about his
arrest this led to widespread protests
all over the city eventually culminating
in the notorious Baltimore riots now you
might be thinking what does it have to
do with racism if black people don't
want to be killed they shouldn't commit
crimes and run away from the police well
the first problem with that is that
extrajudicial executions for nonviolent
crimes shouldn't really be a common
thing in a civilized democracy and it's
a little alarming to me how quick you
are to defend this and the other problem
is that that's a very superficial
analysis that refuses to examine the
deeper reasons why black neighborhoods
tend to have more poverty more crime and
are subject to more aggressive policing
so let's delve a little deeper
starting with Freddie gray as a case
study Bray had a long arrest record of
mostly drug offenses and a lot of
conservative commentators brought this
out as evidence that he was no angel the
implication I guess is that gray simply
gawa was coming to him that he deserved
to die but why did he commit all these
crimes in the first place I don't think
he was selling drugs for lack of
entrepreneurial ambition did he just do
it for no reason well let's see Freddie
gray was born in 1989 in the West
Baltimore neighborhood
sandtown-winchester you can see in this
picture of him as a child that he grew
up in a dilapidated row house with
peeling LED paint
lead was used as a cheap additive at a
house paint until Congress banned it in
1978 because it caused a serious
cognitive damage in children leading to
deficits and attention and increased
aggression which may explain why
children poison the fled are seven times
more likely to drop out of school and
six times more likely to end up in the
juvenile justice system but shitty
Baltimore slumlords often haven't
bothered to comply with a congressional
ban on lead paint and as a result 93
thousand children with lead poisoning
have been added to Maryland's lead
registry and in Baltimore the vast
majority of these children are black
many of
these kids were later awarded structured
settlements as compensation for a
permanent brain damage and Freddie gray
was one of these kids now you might be
thinking well reparations were paid out
so problem solved right well
unfortunately no what's happened is a
sub industry as emerged of shark lawyers
who swooped in on the lead poisoning
victims some of whom can't even read a
contract and offered a buyout they're
structured monthly settlements in
exchange for a lump sum that's a
fraction of the total worth of the
settlement and that's exactly what
happened to Freddie gray in 2013 a
company called access funding bought the
one hundred and forty six thousand
dollar remainder of his settlement for
18 thousand three hundred dollars they
also bought his sister's settlements
acquiring the entire four hundred and
thirty five thousand dollar Graceling
settlement for fifty four thousand
dollars now I hope we can all agree that
this is objectively bad but to
understand how it relates to structural
racism we have to look at Baltimore's
history of racial segregation or you
know we could just keep doing live
streams with Richard Spencer interviews
with Nazis the new YouTube craze god
damn it I need to relax I need music
[Music]
- housing discrimination take a look at
this map which shows Baltimore
neighborhoods with children with
elevated lead levels between 2010 and
2013 and compare it with this map of
Baltimore's racial demographics yellow
dots is standing for black residents and
blue dots standing for white led race
led race also notice how sharp the
divisions are between black and white
neighborhoods why in the 21st century is
Baltimore still so segregated I thought
racism was over well here's the thing
about that when your country's history
is 400 years of slavery Jim Crow and
segregation you don't just get to say oh
sorry about it's all cool now though
right no it's not cool and these maps
are a pretty good illustration of one of
the major not cool things let's look at
how this [ __ ] happened in the first
place I hope I'm not being too
controversial if I propose that a
hundred years ago America may have been
somewhat racist in 1910 a Yale educated
black lawyer named W Ashby Hawkins
bought a house and a prestigious white
Baltimore neighborhood this produced
such an uproar among the way residents
that the city passed an ordinance
mandating the segregation of every
residential block basically the
ordinance forbade black people to buy or
rent houses on majority white blocks and
vice versa until the Supreme Court
overturned the ordinance in 1917 well if
the Supreme Court overturned the Jim
Crow laws then what's the problem
racism can't exist if black people have
all the same rights as white people Wow
now that's actually not correct in 1934
Congress created the Federal Housing
Administration to promote home ownership
in the midst of the Great Depression
when many homes were foreclosed one of
the FHA's purposes was to establish a
reliable credit system backed by the
government which would regulate interest
rates and insure the terms of mortgages
FHA backed loans played a critical role
in facilitating homeownership throughout
the middle of the 20th century the
period many white Americans no remember
as the Golden Age of the American Dream
but many black Americans were excluded
from homeownership and the benefits that
conferred to white families particularly
the family financial stability it
enabled so how was this exclusion
possible well basically the FHA city
governments and white citizens adopted a
variety of subtle methods to enforce
residential segregation and deny home
ownership to black American
for instance one restrictive covenants
when the 1910 ordinance was overturned
Baltimore's mayor created an official
committee on segregation which
cooperated with neighborhood
associations to pressure landlords and
white neighborhoods to sign covenants
committing them never to sell or rent to
black residents these agreements were
enforced through strategic building and
health code citations issued against
owners and by evictions of black renters
who violated the covenant - redlining
the FHA adopted a policy of refusing to
insure mortgages and block neighborhoods
which were colored in red on official
maps giving the practice the name
redlining
this effectively denied black citizens
accessed the government-backed mortgages
which in turn left them vulnerable to
three predatory lending unscrupulous
white sellers took advantage of black
buyers exclusion from FHA backed
mortgages exploiting lacks regulations
to design on fairly priced installment
plans with abusive terms which allowed
for instance sellers to repossess and
resell homes after a single missed
payment many black residents had no
choice but to buy into these
exploitative contracts and they often
resorted to subdividing houses or
neglecting repairs in order to make
payments further contributing to the
overcrowding and decay of black
neighborhoods for blockbusting predatory
real estate agents often used a scheme
known as block busting where they'd
intentionally provoke fear of an
impending minority takeover among
residents of a white neighborhood they
would then exploit the fear that they
created to trick white homeowners into
selling their houses at below market
prices so they could resell those same
houses at extortionate prices to black
families desperate to escape the ghetto
the long-term effect of these practices
was that many black families ended up
trapped in decaying neighborhoods with
bad schools little opportunity cyclical
crime and poverty and aggressive
discriminatory policing and even though
most of these segregation practices have
ended the injustice remains unredressed
no reparations have been paid to black
families who were effectively robbed of
homeownership during this period
predatory lending having cost black
families an estimated five hundred
million dollars in Chicago alone the
worst of all is that segregation and
ghettoization caused by government backs
discrimination of the last century is
still ongoing I'm currently sitting in
my gentrifying white [ __ ] neighborhood
like one mile away from where Freddie
gray was arrested in a neighborhood
that's like a whole different country
here's the 1937 redlining map of
Baltimore
now compare that to the 2013 population
by race map if the 1937 map is the
product of racism and it is and if the
city still follows the same pattern of
segregation today and it does well it's
almost as if the effects of racism have
not entirely been eradicated it is not
just Baltimore that's like this either
here are redlining maps of New York
Chicago Philadelphia Atlanta Detroit New
Orleans Cleveland LA all these cities
are still segregated as [ __ ] and it's
not like a separate but equal situation
either compare the 2013 population by
race map of Baltimore to this map of
Baltimore police stops between 2010 and
2015 that's black neighborhoods and red
and green dots representing recorded
police stops of black pedestrians and
finally let's bring back the map of
childhood lead poisoning between 2010
and 2013 now consider this information
in combination with some scientific
studies linking LED exposure and violent
crime and it almost starts to look like
there's some problems going on here that
might not be solved simply by telling
black teenagers to tighten their belts
and do less crimes but I don't want to
overstate the lead crime theory either
because that only accounts for a small
fraction of what's going on here the
bigger picture is the lasting economic
deprivation caused by segregation
historical exclusion from home ownership
the lost opportunities the bad schools
in this country's ongoing insistence on
treating a problem of injustice as if it
were simply a problem of criminality I
know I said my interest in this topic
isn't a matter of white guilt and it's
not but also fellow White's how do we
sleep at night
in this guided meditation you're going
to relax your body and release your
guilt you're not responsible for what
your great-grandparents did as you use
the tension in each muscle group exhale
deeply and repeat the mantra black lives
matter are the real racists three mass
incarceration since the 1970s the United
States incarceration rate has rapidly
risen to the point where nearly 1 in 100
American men are in jail or prison we
now have the highest incarceration rate
in the world accounting for 22% of the
world's prisoners that we make up only
4.4 percent of the world's population
more than a third of the total
incarcerated population is black and the
black incarceration rate is almost six
times that of whites now without even
bringing race into it it's clear that
America has a prison problem in general
sentences are too long too many
nonviolent drug offenders are in prison
too many defendants are pressured into
plea bargains in a private prison
industry incentivizes high rates of
incarceration but disproportionately
people of color are victimized by this
system now a lot of people are going to
look at the incarceration data and say
if the blocks don't like going to jail
they should just do less crimes let's do
another interview with Richard Spencer
you know what why don't we all interview
with you Spencer every single YouTube
free speech mandates that we all
constantly broadcast fascist propaganda
let's get them all in here every single
Nazi and one giant live stream and then
we can finally give the Jewish Question
the platform it deserve Saad damn it
where's my toad venom look it's just not
always the case that black people are
imprisoned more because they commit more
crimes for instance black and white
people use weed at about the same rate
but black people are nearly four times
as likely to be arrested for it and
we're talking about a drug that at this
point white America has basically
decided shouldn't really even be illegal
anyway so we've now got a ten billion
dollar legal marijuana industry and just
look what white people are doing to weed
mark Smith is the CEO of tumbleweed at a
ganja preneur it's a strong strong
sativa very high in lye meaning it's a
great bronchodilator so I like to use it
when I work out yeah so in fact in the
back of the limousine is only the one of
the only legal places you can consume
cannabis the whites are at it again
they have gentrified to the marijuana
and now we've got white businesspeople
making millions of dollars selling the
same drug that black people are still
disproportionally incarcerated for
having sold ganja preneur do i do it
then gold on my fingers this is the most
basic kind of unfairness and if this
doesn't make you angry then either
you're really ignorant about this or you
might just not care about black people I
don't like to assume the worst of people
but when I look at the state of the
conversation about race in America I see
a lot of people who are willing to just
wave away the extrajudicial executions
of black people by the police the mass
incarceration of people of color and the
vicious history of discrimination in its
ongoing repercussions and from those
same people I see a tendency to get
extremely outraged by any black person
who takes a stand or takes a knee or
speaks up about this in any way there's
an endless mill of content about how
authoritarian and evil black lives
matter is and how its identity politics
equivalent to white nationalism and it's
unpatriotic and postmodern and racist
and I'm sorry but this group of creators
are being really melodramatic black
college students complaining too loudly
are not Orwell's nightmare if anything
in this country deserves to be called an
authoritarian nightmare it's locking
people in cages for decades over drug
offenses but right wing YouTube doesn't
seem very interested in using their free
speech to talk about that they're too
busy complaining about people using
their free speech to protests how dare
they now I can also anticipate another
objection that doesn't come from YouTube
fascists or stock salad-eating basic
white girl caricatures I imagine some
black people will probably watch this
video and think where does this white
[ __ ] get off telling me I'm a victim I
take responsibility for my own life
instead of blaming all my problems on
racism and here's the thing about that
you're actually right in the sense that
taking responsibility or taking control
of your life to the greatest extent
possible is actually a good way to live
your life as an individual so by all
means don't allow yourself to be defined
by victimhood do take control of your
destiny as much as possible so I'm not
saying anyone should blame all their
problems on bigotry and wallow and
victimhood please don't do that
go succeed as much as possible but also
while you're succeeding don't deny that
oppressive circumstances exist yes it's
possible for individuals to escape
oppressive circumstances but we also
have a collective duty to work to
eliminate the unjust conditions that
create those circumstances in the first
place wow I feel like I just gave a
great speech
would you take my speech less seriously
if you knew I
had been drinking Bud Light Lime this
entire time look I even put a lime in it
but light lime with lime
the official beverage of people who
complain about people who complained too
much about people who complain too much
about racism for the final countdown I
want to say two more things before I
flee into the forest first there
actually are more racial groups in
America than just black people and white
people I've just narrowed the topic of
discussion so this video isn't three
hours long but there are lots of other
kinds of racism in this country and
someone should make videos about those
too second please don't get all your
information from YouTube I've put some
links in the description with my sources
and some further reading on the topic
also don't get all your information
about race and racism from white people
like come on that should just be common
stuff so when this video ends what you
should do is scroll down smash that
unsubscribe button on a click that
little bell so you no longer receive
notifications about my videos and then
you should go subscribe to a bunch of
people of color and listen to what they
have to say um so like guess that's it
I'm just kidding about the forests I
don't [ __ ] with forests I'm really more
of an indoor [ __ ] so I guess I'll just
go sing a song about fighting racists
mine eyes have seen
he is trampling out the vintage where
The Grapes of Wrath are stoned
he hath loosed the fateful lightning of
his terrible Swift sword his
[Music]
as he died to make men holy let us died
to make men free
[Music]
no regard
that's the capitalism and the patriarchy
smash the binary hail Satan